une bonne nouvelle et si nous partons en
retraite à 40 ans et c'est et c'est
possible et c'est possible regardez
alors que les contestations contre le
recul de l'âge du départ à la retraite
font toujours rage dans l'Hexagone
[Musique]
Victor Laura vient de sortir un ouvrage
dans lequel il fait une affirmation choc
la retraite à 40 ans c'est possible de
venir entier à 30 ans celui qui a
travaillé dans le monde de la finance
avant de diriger une startup a pu cesser
de travailler très jeune j'ai 33 ans et
je suis à la retraite à travers son
livre le jeune homme souhaite
aujourd'hui nous livrer ses précieux
conseils pour accéder à une liberté
financière alors comment y est-il
parvenu la retraite à 40 ans c'est
possible Victor Laura nous explique
comment faire ce soir dans TPMP
[Musique]
la retraite à 40 ans c'est possible
Victor Laura alors c'est pas les numéros
du loto c'est vraiment une vraie
technique pour ne plus travailler je
vous avoue qu'on est un peu sceptique
sur le principe quel âge avez-vous alors
là j'ai 34 ans donc d'accord vous ne
travaillez plus alors je travaille
toujours
d'accord et vous avez mis au point une
méthode qui devrait nous permettre à
tout arrêter à 40 ans c'est ça donc
c'est une méthode qui vient des
États-Unis donc englissisme ça s'appelle
fire
indepanon retire early alors retire
c'est la retraite Orly c'est tout c'est
ça fire c'est le feu
à ta vie et à atomes
expliquez-nous parce que là il y a des
je vois des gens là
ont des personnes qui ont qui ont
travaillé pendant 40 ans
et on a et qui se disent quand même j'ai
très travaillé 40 ans de trop en fait
donc on est quand même intéressé alors
de règles à suivre c'est ça première
règle première règle c'est de savoir ce
qu'on veut dans la vie donc ce qu'on
veut c'est je vous répond à moi du
pognon par exemple alors ça c'est un peu
plus compliqué après il y a d'autres de
stade donc Benjamin je vous ai suivi
vous je pense que c'est plutôt dans les
100 millions je crois être riche etc ce
qui est intéressant alors on parlera
après
pour les autres personnes c'est de se
dire ok où est-ce qu'on veut habiter
qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire ce qu'on va
voir des enfants est-ce qu'on va voir
des parents à charge on prend tout ça on
fait un budget de ça et on sait combien
de combien on a besoin tous les mois en
fait pour vivre d'accord j'ai 6 enfants
par exemple dans ce cas là ça fait
beaucoup là ça commence à taper et en
plus si on vit à Paris et si on aime
bien les belles choses dans son
quotidien ça peut faire beaucoup
d'argent il y a une question que vous
posez qui est intéressante c'est pouvoir
vivre dans ce qu'on veut ou dans ce
qu'on peut oui c'est ça moi je voudrais
bien tout en fait
alors mais en fait dans votre cas
pendant pas mal de temps c'était
possible enfin vous êtes très successful
vous étiez très successful sur TF1
beaucoup d'argent donc on peut faire ce
qu'on veut ça va mais pour la plupart
d'entre nous il y a des mois il y a des
limites ce que vous avez aujourd'hui il
y a des limites on peut plus voilà on
peut plus
et quand on est limité il faut se dire
ok déjà il y a ce qu'on veut d'un côté
et après qu'est-ce qu'on peut réellement
faire et après il faut trouver un état
un état des lieux et voilà j'ai un
enfant deux enfants ou je veux un ou
deux enfants me marier alors le mariage
étant un voilà c'est bon voilà donc ça
peut coûter un peu cher surtout quand on
divorce donc ça va on va ça va si on va
aider ses parents ou pas ça c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que si on a ses parents à
charge ça change quand même la donne
c'est très cher c'est très cher alors ça
dépend mais alors en gros en faisant
c'est un peu cette formule je me fais un
peu l'avocat du diable je pense que tout
le monde sera d'accord avec moi si on
fait un peu c'est cet état des choses
quels sont les gens ou combien il y en a
qui peuvent se dire ok moi c'est bon en
40 ans je crois que 9 sur 10 voire 10
sur 10 ils disent bon ben je peux pas
avoir la retraite à 40 ans alors dès
qu'on fait ça déjà on a on estime la
Somme et après effectivement quand on
regarde alors après si on regarde la
France de façon générale après faut se
lancer dans un mouvement faut comprendre
est-ce qu'on est capable de le faire ou
pas vous vous pouvez vous dater de
bosser vous pourriez moi alors j'ai
arrêté déjà j'ai quitté mon j'ai quitté
mon emploi quand j'avais 32 ans du coup
et là moi j'ai continué enfin je crée là
j'ai créé une école pour de la
reconversion professionnelle je suis
dans des projets à sens ce que je pense
qu'on a besoin vous avez un peu une
destinée un peu artistique avec des
idées vous êtes un peu entrepreneur dans
l'âme les gens qui sont qui sont
boulangers qui sont charcutiers qui sont
à l'usine si vous leur dit bah ils vont
vous répondre bah oui comment je fais
alors comment on fait concrètement une
fois qu'on a ce budget là il y a
plusieurs étapes première étape on
reprend en main c'est finance donc en
gros on a dedans il y a des gens qui
reprend nos mains pas grand chose vite
être pris en main oui ils ont déjà plus
de pognon le 15 du mois donc ils vont
prendre alors dans ce cas là c'est
compliqué il y a des situations
non non en fait 900 alors 9 c'est du je
suis pas sûr que ce soit 910 mais en
tout cas quand en fait il y a
différentes choses donc il y a des
personnes qui d'un côté peuvent être à
la fin du mois et encore avoir des
revenus là c'est bon et encore avoir des
fonds et sinon il y a les autres
personnes ou il faut trouver des
solutions et les solutions il y en a pas
36000 donc une fois alors je prends du
principe qu'une personne est capable en
fin de mois d'avoir d'être dans une
situation elle peut avoir de l'argent
côté une fois qu'elle a fait ça il y a
plusieurs éléments première élément mais
là il y a des gens qui nous regardent
qui hurlent devant leur télé je vous le
dis et il y a des gens il y a des gens
il y a des gens qui font le choix entre
entre un steak et autre chose et vous
leur expliquer que tout le monde pourra
mettre 10 balles de côté c'est je crois
honnêtement je pense pas alors moi je ne
pense pas non plus j'ai pas dit que tout
le monde pouvait faire le après ça avec
quel métier on peut faire ça pour être
très concret parce que franchement 90%
des métiers on peut pas du tout faire ce
que vous appliquez avec quel métier on
peut faire ça alors banquier cadre
avocat médecin
sincèrement les revenus médias en France
si on prend plutôt de m'appliquer c'est
2400 euros
non par 100 personnes 2400 euros 2400 si
on prend l'Insee c'est 1850 si on prend
les revenus Toto parce qu'il y a les
aides etc c'est 2400 on est en couple ça
fait déjà une bonne forme donc on est
proche de aller à 5000 euros 4000 4800
travail si les deux travaillent si les
deux travaillent dans ce cas là on peut
déjà se lancer là-dedans ça veut dire
que vu que c'est médian c'est-à-dire que
la moitié des Français peuvent le faire
donc on n'est pas dans 90 % etc
j'entends les gens dans le public je
pense qu'il y a peu de gens qui gagnent
4800 euros à deux j'ai honnêtement enfin
c'est voilà non mais enfin non c'est pas
tout le monde qui gagne 4800 euros
en France le revenu d'un d'un coup c'est
autour de 4500 avec les aides les
subventions l'École etc etc c'est ça et
en fait en fonction des différents
profils il y a différentes stratégies
donc si on est dans le cas un peu médian
médian supérieur donc dans la tranche
supérieure on met de l'argent de côté on
épargne on réplique un peu modèle
américain on investit une partie en
bourse à prendre du temps mais ça marche
au bout d'un moment et après on enchaîne
dans l'immobilier on multiplie les
opérations et après on passe je vous dis
les gens regarde ils disent mais il est
au pays de oui oui le mec parce que
parce que vous parlez aussi de
frugalisme c'est ça donc dans les
méthodes pour mettre de côté ou on est
moins frugal alors non non en fait pour
les méthodes de côté grosso modo quand
est-ce qu'on aime bien dans la vie quand
on habite par exemple à Paris ou quand
on habite proche de Paris on va vouloir
sortir on va on va consommer son argent
en fait tous les mois on va partir du
principe que on a de l'argent en plus il
y a le loyer et le reste je peux le
consommer et en fait là il y a un gros
boulot à faire ou là on se dit ok en
fait faut pas consommer cet argent là il
faut en épargner une partie et ça c'est
dur parce que tout de suite on voit pas
un resto les en faire 3 par exemple
c'est ça en fait en résumé vous pensez
que les gens consomment trop
moi je pense alors moi je pense que
peut-être non ça dépend du ça dépend en
fait ça dépend de vos objectifs si vos
objectifs honnêtement j'essaie de
comprendre parce que je pense que
quelqu'un qui comprennent pas du tout ce
que vous racontez d'accord quand on est
dans une situation compliquée et que on
compte tout déjà et je vois pas comment
on peut expliquer à des gens d'être un
peu moins frugal vu qu'ils vont déjà
rien de moins sachez le frein ils en
achète jamais de moins les restos ils y
vont jamais et de mettre un cinéma sur
deux alors qu'ils n'ont pas il parle de
ceux qui peuvent donc c'est en plus dans
un contexte économique on n'arrête pas
de dire que c'est compliqué une
catastrophe totale donc c'est compliqué
d'entendre ça j'espère que vous enfin je
vous ai peut-être raison mais c'est
compliqué à mettre en oeuvre en tous les
cas c'est pas réservé une élite en fait
alors méthode pour moi c'est réservé aux
50% enfin alors ça dépend ce qu'on
comment on le fait comme on le voit mais
en tout cas cette partie où on économise
etc c'est pour 50% des français qui sont
au dessus du revenu médian donc à 50%
d'accord donc là déjà on a ça pour ceux
qui sont dans d'autres situations où là
c'est vraiment précaire il y a d'autres
choses à faire si on peut pas si on est
déjà dans une situation dans le rouge
effectivement on va pas se mettre à
économiser mais là il y a d'autres il y
a d'autres éléments à faire
moi je m'adresse plutôt aux 50% qui sont
en capacité d'épargner moi c'est là
c'est là où je communique et les autres
ça je l'ai pas encore traité j'ai pas
encore traité cette partie là en fait
moi je pense que je préférais qu'on
s'intéresse à 50 % qui on y arrive pas
que 50 % qui sont déjà au-dessus du
panier mais l'écriture
on peut après voilà un livre d'accord
vous avez écrit votre livre
quand alors je l'ai écrit avant
l'inflation avant tout le sujet
d'aujourd'hui je l'ai écrit c'est pour
ça il y a 2 ans et demi donc vous êtes
quand même beaucoup beaucoup inspiré du
best-seller how to get rich non
exactement ça ce que vous racontez en
fait il y a des tendances
on peut retrouver je vais expliquer
juste que c'est c'est un américain qui a
écrit ça qui est un la finance vous
devez connaître j'imagine que vous
l'avez lu parce que c'est exactement ce
que vous racontez il y a une série
maintenant sur Netflix que vous pouvez
regarder qui s'appelle how to get rich
voilà où il explique en fait le ce
monsieur qui est dans la finance comment
en fait gérer son budget voilà donc
c'est en fait la gestion du budget qui
est en fait un peu du bon sens ce que
vous dites que ce que vous reprenez mais
ce qui m'a étonné c'est le fait de
reprendre la retraite parce que là c'est
quand même le buzz du moment la retraite
à 40 ans ça vous aviez déjà écrit ça il
y a deux ans et demi la retraite à 40
ans ou c'est un peu un truc marketing
que vous faites aujourd'hui pour que ça
fonctionne non mais ce qui est très
intelligent de votre part en fait mais
je suis pas si c'est intelligent en fait
c'est sorti avant
toute la retraite
Sophie on dit de Victoria qu'il est
visionnaire parce que il a quand même
des vrais conseils pour essayer de
d'améliorer les choses parce que là je
vous taquine un peu parce que c'est vrai
que le contexte fait que ça doit
hérisser les poils des gens de qu'on
explique ça mais c'est mais vous avez
forcément en train vous avez sûrement
raison non mais il a raison parce que
quand on regarde la série justement qui
est vachement intéressant on se rend
compte finalement et personnellement
aussi qu'on ne sait pas gérer son budget
quel que soit les ressources qu'on a
voilà donc ça c'est intéressant en SLAs
que raconte monsieur c'est effectivement
que l'on met tant que l'on n'est plus ou
que l'on est moins la gestion du budget
c'est on se quand on se plante
et vous vous avez réussi quel est votre
fortune aujourd'hui alors je pourrais
arrêter
c'est intéressant
en fait de façon assez simple parce que
je vous aime beaucoup j'aime beaucoup
suivre ce que vous faites ici du coup
en fait quand vous faites les calculs on
pourrait faire une réponse simple en
gros si vous voulez 2000 euros par mois
il faut avoir 600.000 euros investi
avec 2000 euros par mois
vous vivez et là vous vivez avec si
c'est bien placé quand même c'est pas
ouf mais c'est censé être stable dans le
temps bon après faut ces investissements
qui normalement marchent
pourquoi vous me regardez quand vous
dites ça je me sens un petit peu
qu'on donne des conseils parce que le
nœud de tout ça va le problème de tout
ça c'est qu'effectivement on surconsomme
et on consomme mal il y a vraiment des
choses à savoir pour consommer de faire
autant plaisir en dépensant beaucoup
moins quelles sont ses conseils alors
les conseils de façon globale c'est au
lieu de penser à un budget c'est de se
dire ok je peux aller par exemple une
fois au restaurant par semaine ou toutes
les deux semaines pour 20 euros déjà
c'est fixé et après on ne dépense que ça
20 euros ça dépend
la laitue alors en vrai ça fonctionne
pour tout donc en fonction du budget de
chacun si vous vous avez un budget
supérieur vous pouvez dire ok j'ai une
fois au restaurant c'est 100 euros par
semaine si ça vous permet derrière
d'atteindre votre objectif et après vous
faites la même chose pour les vacances
en fait vous faites des paquets pour
chacune de vos dépenses vous faites des
réflexes et une fois que vous avez ces
réflexes là vous ne pensez plus pour par
exemple vous savez ce que vous avez
pensé à une fois vous y avez un inventé
ça c'est pour encore une fois le cas des
personnes qui sont dans les 50%. il y a
aussi une idée de anticiper ces vacances
très en avance pour payer un petit bout
tous les mois comme ça on le sent pas
passer c'est ça vous fait du budget
c'est pareil vous voulez acheter un
nouveau téléphone en fait vous savez que
votre téléphone vous le garder 3 ans et
du coup tous les mois où était 10 € de
côté pour votre téléphone en fait ça
vous permet de vous responsabiliser par
rapport au coup que vous avez réellement
et ce que ça vous coûte est-ce que ça
explique aussi il y a il y a une
explosion de tout ce qui est magasin
d'occasion et honnêtement quand on voit
ce qu'il faut en occasion c'est
totalement reconditionné c'est en
parfait état et on gagne quoi 50% 100%
bah ça dépend on peut gagner
effectivement alors je sais pas mais au
moins 50% en face ça dépend des versions
et de ce qu'on achète etc en fait
l'enjeu c'est de se dire que finalement
là on nous vend des choses qui sont
neufs on va nous vendre des alors
maintenant tout le monde le sait on
utilise vintage des marques qui nous
permet d'acheter des sites qui me permet
d'acheter d'occasion mais en fait il
faut se mettre dans une réflexion où il
y a des choses qui nous apportent pas
forcément plus de bonheur donc par
exemple aller prendre une bière avec un
ami dans un bar où la bière elle est à
3,50 €. est-ce que ça change vraiment
quand c'est un ami ou d'aller dans un
endroit où la bière coûte 20 euros ça
donc il y a des réflexes comme ça sur la
partie de la gestion financière et c'est
surtout de comprendre ce qu'on dépense
je comprends si c'est bien pour nous ou
pas oui Sacha j'ai beaucoup de respect
pour vous monsieur Laurent mais lorsque
on voit votre livre la retraite à 40 ans
du coup on idéalise une retraite jeune
et en fait jusqu'à cette retraite là on
se prive on se prive d'aller au
restaurant on se prive de faire plaisir
à ses parents on se prive d'aller en
vacances dans des beaux endroits vous
avez même je crois une technique pour
dire voilà si on veut s'acheter des
trucs on doit faire un top 5 et si celui
qu'on veut s'acheter bah il est encore
dans le top 5 trois mois après on peut
se l'acheter ça veut dire que la raison
c'est pas ça veut dire qu'on ne peut pas
se faire des kiffes et lorsqu'on arrive
à 40 ans bah par exemple nos parents ils
sont peut-être un peu un petit peu plus
vieux donc c'est compliqué de partir en
vacances avec eux c'est compliqué de les
amener faire des activités de profiter
etc donc ça veut dire qu'on a tout un
pan de la vie où on est jeune on est
dynamique etc ou on profite pas on doit
mettre à cause déjà que c'est compliqué
de mettre de l'argent de côté ça veut
dire que là on se prive de tout puisque
40 ans mais sauf qu'après c'est
compliqué de choses là honnêtement si
vous voulez améliorer votre façon de
consommer vous interroger sur comment on
peut consommer mieux consommer moi moi
je vous conseille ça fortement la
retraite à 40 ans merci beaucoup
Monsieur Merci beaucoup